[Musique]
à manier les hameaux ou trois listes
sont déclarés à ce jour celle du maire
sortant bertrand au lion celle en cours
de constitution encore de dominique
gratin et puis celle de lionel lindeman
il venait de ma de bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau
vous êtes tête de liste mme annie
citoyens c'est une liste de tendance
centre droit et aussi des adhérents
république en marche
vous siégez en tant qu élue d'opposition
depuis 2014 dans cette commune de magny
les hameaux
vous étiez candidat avec aurore bergé
qui est aujourd'hui députée pour autant
il n'y a pas d'investiture officielle
sur votre liste je parlais des
différentes tendances mais elle a plus
on nous a proposé plusieurs plusieurs
investitures et on a refusé parce qu'on
considère que c'est un enjeu totalement
locales et les considérations nationales
sont à vrai dire tout à fait secondaire
ce dont il s'agit c'est manille et
paraît pas d'autres
d'autres considérations par contre on
cache pas qui on est donc effectivement
on a des membres du comité local manière
marche qu'ils ont décidé d'intégrer la
liste qui ont tissé de digne de
participer parce qu'ils ont des
compétences vraiment très intéressante
donc c'est vraiment des gens qui vont
pouvoir apporter à la commune de
nouvelles compétences que à mon sens
elle n'a pas pour l'instant
et sinon on a 80 % la liste en fait
c'est d'aider à politique en fait donc
il n'y a pas de raison d'avoir une
étiquette particulière après moi je ne
cache pas que je suis plutôt de centre
droit pour que les gens sachent à qui
ils ont affaire j'ai pas enfin rendre
c'était une liste centre droit donc
c'est quoi et revoir de 2014 il ya
beaucoup d'évolution vous reprenez une
partie la totalité des noms présents la
dernière fois la totalité non parce que
certains ont quitté la commune
on a des personnes qui étaient vraiment
très très intéressante mais qui
déménageait son ami les chevreuse par
exemple donc évidemment on va pas les
reprendre parce qu'on considère que
quand quand on se présente à l'élection
municipale il faut vivre sur la commune
par contre on rejoue il ya une grosse
partie effectivement de renouvellement
depuis
oui oui lui 2014 nécessairement en 2014
votre liste dans votre liste avait été
battu le maire sortant avait totalisé 58
26 % comment vous pensez pouvoir
inverser ce ce score ce résultat qu'est
ce qui a changé depuis le dernier
scrutin
justement il ya le fait qu' on est six
ans après et que le maire a maintenant
un bilan
quels sont vos reproches sur ce bilan
justement ce qui va nous amener il
suffit de regarder les engagements en
fard qu'il avait pris
je pense à deux engagements en
particulier qui pour moi sont ces
symboles et même symptomatique
de ce qu'on peut lui reprocher même s'il
ya aussi eu des choses très positives
dans ce qui a été fait il s'était engagé
à mettre en place un marché à manier les
eaux et ce marché c'est très important
parce qu'on a une commune il ya trente
ans encore il y avait des débats sur
est-ce qu'on va couper la commune en
deux est-ce qu'on va lasser inde etc
donc c'est une commune qui a absolument
besoin de centres et de créer des liens
et donc ce marché extrêmement important
parce que c'est il permettrait à tous
les manier quoi de se voir tous les
week-ends de ceux de se rencontrer et
ainsi de suite
il a été promis il ya six ans et puis on
est six ans plus tard il ya toujours pas
de marché et donc au delà des étiquettes
d ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut voir c'est
est ce que ma mère quand il se continue
quand il se présente à une élection
quand il propose un projet s qui tient
ses engagements ou paraît donc là dessus
c'est pas le cas autre autre domaine où
il s'était engagé à de la modération
fiscale s'étaient s'était décrit de
façon très claire dans son dans son
projet et puis alors après les impôts à
manille augmenter de le loto des impôts
communaux a augmenté de 10%
donc moi pour moi ça c'est pas de la
modération fiscale et ça aussi c'est un
engagement qui n'a pas été tenue
ce à quoi le maire pour qui n'est pas là
et vous aurez l'occasion d'échanger
lorsqu'il y aura les débats qui seront
proposés sur notre antenne pourrait
aussi répondre qu'il ya un désengagement
de la part de l'état ceux-ci faire face
quand on est maire il se bat c'est c'est
un discours qui tient qui tient
régulièrement
il se trouve qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
mères qui n'ont pas fait ce choix là moi
je connais un certain nombre je suis
proche d'un maire qui lui a fait le
choix malgré le désengagement de l'état
ne peut pas ne pas augmenter les impôts
parce qu'ils s'y était engagé aux
élections on n'aime pas le faire elle ne
l'a pas fait et en réalité cinq ans
après six ans après lui il me parle plus
du désengagement de l'état il me dit il
me parle de l'avenir de sa commune est
en réalité il a il a fait face à ce
désagrément des engagements et sa
commune est beaucoup plus forte
aujourd'hui ses finances sont beaucoup
plus fortes aujourd'hui parce que il a
fait face à cette difficulté dans votre
programme il ya donc cette volonté de
fédérer la commune autour d'un marché
notamment il ya aussi cette idée de
sortir du désenclavement c'est un point
qui revient régulièrement dans les
différentes campagnes sur magny les
hameaux de par sa construction sa
position géographique
quelles sont vos propositions justement
pour pouvoir sortir cette commune un peu
de son éloignement du reste de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et désenclaver
un peu mais l'environnement le le
problème que pose enfin nous ont tous
été vraiment que c'est là c'est le
domaine clé où il faut agir parce qu'en
fait tout le reste va suivre c'est à
dire que si vous voulez des entreprises
s'installent à manille il faut que les
salariés de ces entreprises puissent
venir à manier donc voilà si vous voulez
que les habitants trouvent
des opportunités à manille même il faut
que ces entreprises puissent puisse
venir à manille et ainsi de suite
donc nous ce qu'on propose pour sortir
de ce désenclavement c'est notamment des
alternatives à la voiture individuelle
il ya eu des pistes cyclables qui ont
été mises en place ou des bandes
cyclables mais elles sont pas sécurisées
donc personne ne s'en sert donc il faut
revoir tout ça elles ne sont pas
directes
il ya aussi dans de ce désenclavement de
la commune oui ça passe par quoi d'autre
le désenclavement et le désenclavement
la commune bien ça passe en augmentant
les bus en travaillant avec nos
partenaires la communauté
d'agglomération pour augmenter les bus
le soir et le week end
j'ai vu qu'il y avait eu des bus express
qui ont été mis en place
tout ça c'est très intéressant sauf que
quand il ya des bouchons ça sert à rien
d'avoir un bus express par exemple le
travail avec l'agglomération justement
c'est aussi l'un de vos points de
programme c'est mieux échanger avec
l'agglomération quelle que soit la
majorité ac en série que vous disiez pas
d'étiquette par exemple mais c'est
quelque chose qui me frappe
quand je parle à l'extérieur de la
commune avec avec nos partenaires pour
préparer les élections
moi je constate que assez souvent ce que
me disent les partenaires de la commune
c'est qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à
travailler avec la commune de magny et
donc moi je considère qu'un maire
aujourd'hui jeu justement doit
travailler avec tous les partenaires
extérieurs de la commune qu'ils
s'agissent de l'état qu'il s'agisse du
département qu'il s'agisse de la région
qu'il s'agisse de la communauté
d'agglomération qu'il s'agisse des
entreprises et ça c'est vraiment un
domaine où pour l'instant les retours
que nous avons sont négatifs la campagne
officielle va débuter l'an 10 3 février
comment va se dérouler votre campagne
sur le terrain des réunions sont déjà
prévus en fait nous on privilégie le
le porte à porte parce qu'on considère
qu'il faut aller voir les habitants
c'est aussi lié à notre commune faire
une réunion dans un coin de la commune
alors qu'on a une commune qui s'étend
sur 7 km c'est toujours réducteur donc
on préfère pour l'instant aller voir les
habitants ou qu'on discute dans tous les
quartiers en fait on a des binômes par
quartier qui ont vocation ensuite à
devenir maire adjoint au maire de
quartier
c'est ça l'idée du coup les habitants
les identifie cesser leur mère de
cartier ou de l'amour donc on va
continuer on a on a démarré on fait ça
depuis depuis décembre et puis à la fin
février effectivement noir avant un
meeting pour réunir tout le monde mais
on va surtout faire une campagne de
terrain on va aller voir les gens on va
discuter avec eux des réunions
d'appartement il ya ainsi de suite et
puis on tout au long du mois on va
décliner nos propositions par thématique
lionel lindemann d'être passé sur se
place au candidat donc sur magny les
hameaux à tête de liste et je rappelle
que de trois listes sont déclarés pour
le moment